If you open up the documentation,
you can see a couple of examples
of typical screen widths.
Then it suggests how you can setup
your layout folders,
so that you can have
a different mean activity layout
for tablet's versus for handsets.
Here we define tablet's as having
a smallest width of at least 600dp.
To customize the UI further,
we can create a layout-sw720dp folder.
That way, we can have
a different main activity layout
for ten inch tablet's versus
for seven inch tablet's
versus for handsets.
So back to our quiz.
We need to define activity_main.xml file
in our base layout folder
so that we can accomplish
this layout on the phone.
This layout applies to both phone,
portrait, and landscape,
so we don't need a special version
of the layout in the layout land folder.
We do also need to declare
activitymain.xml
in the layout-sw600dp folder.
That way it will override the one pane UI
and use a two pane UI in this case.
It will be picked up on devices
that have greater than 600dp
in both width and height.
That means seven inch and ten inch devices
in both portrait and landscape mode.
And lastly, we don't need layout-sw720dp
because we don't have different layouts
for seven inch versus ten inch devices.